having trans friends is like having
friends you were shaking I was shaking I
was sweating shaking at the table and
then I knew I was like oh yeah
here we go and then I just came out and
talked to her yeah I got her I got it
I've seen a confidence come out of you
that I didn't see in the beginning this
just brought you out to a whole new
level I fix her - my impression of you
was your tall skinny and pretty I just
used to haven't told me hey guy haven't
you resign until today okay let's go
Catherine hey I'm a woman of trans
experience it's beautiful you can want
to cry you I don't know if I should say
this but you had a different name at the
time I did have a different name that
was awesome but I also think that your
name is equally awesome I don't think it
changes what I think about you as a
friend I think our relationship is is
built on the moments we've had together
so what do you feel is the difference
having me as a friend being trans versus
when you're with your sister ends when
you were transitioning I felt a little
more protective for a long time now
you've just been with one of my
girlfriends I want you guys to see me
ask me and you still treated me like one
of your girlfriends and talked about
boyish ooh yeah any boy issues were you
scared that I would get like attacked in
the men's restroom when I was still
using it there was just a point where I
rather you just come into the same
restroom as me I enter any men's room
going oh please I hope nobody notices
that I'm going into the stall and
realizes that I might not be cisgender I
never saw us here today and so I can
really what did you see honestly I
didn't even think I'd live this long
really yeah see that's crazy I hope you
don't lose faith in humanity somehow it
will change and keep being your fabulous
self because girls like me who look up
to you for their definition of what can
be sexy your sexy to throw
I don't even know if I'd have had the
guts to transition if it wasn't for
people like you so early on who helped
and reinforced that I am worthy of being
loved in the beginning you were sort of
this masculine figure in my life that's
something that I always appreciated cuz
you were just there to be like my
brother what you do for family you kind
of introduced me to a world in a culture
that I wasn't aware of before I think
that I've become a more richer and a
richer person yeah awesome right
definitely pushes me to want to be like
be the woman I guess but I want to be ah
that's amazing
it's true I love thank you thank you for
sure can we hug now yes yeah oh the only
really upsetting thing about having
trans friends I will say and I thought
about this as well is they are all far
more attractive than I am and it's
really infuriating
you